welcome back before we go we like to
play a quick round up truth or dare
all right
do we have carmi regrandio
hi
hi there uh okay best suit of the day
hello thank you
all right so what's it gonna be today is
it gonna be a truth or a dare uh
dare okay
i like how you revved up for
it coming down the pike you ready i
think so yes always yes true okay i dare
you to try to crack an egg
without getting any shell in the bowl
but
there's a twist
ross will be behind you
and you have to use his hands instead of
your own and
ross will be blindfolded oh i already
like you yeah your hands will be behind
your back and you have to guide ross
the entire time okay
your hands my eyes yes and we'll work as
a unit yes
[Applause]
okay
all right drew remember
no shell no shell in the bowl okay this
is the blindfold wear your apron
okay i'm gonna put this i don't want you
to get dirty so i'm going to put a
little thank you that's cute you ready
all right qqq you strapped me in i'll
strap you in oh
um okay blind told me okay here eh and
even though i'm in the heels thank you
rossi you can do this i'm gonna get
behind you
guide me okay
forward okay okay and now go down and
get the yeah
yeah okay
now wait okay no okay keep your hands
straight well girl come on i can't do
straight your hand
keep your hands straight
okay okay now one two three
i don't think that worked all right pick
the ball up click yeah
okay now oh yeah get that egg out
okay
here we go
okay
okay now count me in okay
right there right there right there yeah
i'm gonna do a little softer
[Laughter]
okay ready three two
delicate oh okay oh no this is not going
to go it's going to go great all right
okay
any shell in the bowl
carmi i'm really sad to tell you there's
a tiny bit of shell but i am very proud
of rossi because not only did the last
egg he get in the bowl it didn't he he
didn't break the yolk thank you so much
how'd i do
look
oh god i didn't break it how about that
hey
good job that wasn't bad
well thank you carmi i have to say drew
that one really cracked me up
[Music]